Sometimes the truth is stranger than
fiction. And today I'm going to tell you
three stories that demonstrate that. But
before we get into those stories, if
you're a fan of the strange, dark, and
mysterious delivered in story format,
then you've come to the right place
because that's all we do and we upload
once a week. So if that's of interest to
you, the next time you're at the beach
with the like button, wait until they
take off their sun hat to go run into
the water. And while they're gone, fill
their hat up with mayonnaise. Also,
please subscribe to our channel and turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
any of our weekly uploads. Okay, let's
get into today's stories.
[Music]
On the afternoon of June 29th, 1934, a
37-year-old police officer named Captain
Alan Falby pressed the throttle on his
police motorcycle and sped down a street
in El Paso, Texas. Captain Falby's
motorcycle lights and sirens were on
because he was chasing a speeding pickup
truck down the road. But despite the
fact that obviously Captain Falby was in
pursuit of this person, they were not
slowing down at all. So, Captain Falby
had been a police officer for 11 years
and he loved his job. He loved his
motorcycle and he hated when suspects
got away. So, he kept his hand on the
throttle and kept chasing down the
suspect. But suddenly, the truck he was
going after slammed on its brakes and
swerved hard to the left. Falby tried to
slow down, but it was too late. He
slammed into the back of this truck and
then he and his bike went sliding across
the asphalt for a few seconds. And the
whole time FB is feeling his body
getting totally scraped against the
pavement and the winds getting knocked
out of him. And then finally when he
came to a stop, you know, he was spled
out in the middle of the road and his
motorcycle, his beloved motorcycle was
laying on top of him, pinning his legs
under him. And this bike weighed like
500 lb. And adding insult to injury
here, you know, as Falby is screaming
out in pain because obviously horrible
injuries have been sustained here, you
know, he looks down the road and he sees
the truck he was chasing who clearly
knew he just wrecked behind them.
They're not going to stay and help. They
just drove off protecting themselves.
And so pretty quickly, Falby kind of
assessed the situation he was in. You
know, he tried for a second to to push
this bike off of him, but not only could
he not move it, but every time he moved
it just a little bit, the weight would
kind of come down even harder and a
little bit more pointed on his legs,
which were crushed, and he had this
excruciating pain down there. And worse,
he's looking underneath him and he's
seeing this growing pool of blood.
Clearly, he sustained potentially
life-threatening injuries here, and he's
all alone, like there's nobody here to
help him, and he's totally stuck. And so
even though he began calling out for
help, the reality was, you know, if
nobody came along soon, he was done for.
And he found himself starting to panic.
Luckily though, just then, two men from
down the road came running up to Captain
Falby. Apparently, they had been sort of
behind the captain and were watching him
pursuing this truck and they had
actually seen the accident. And so they
had pulled over and they were now
running up to see if he was okay. And so
right away, without even needing to ask
Captain Falby what he needed, these two
men saw the situation. You know, the
bike is pinned on top of the cop. And so
together, these two men were able to
lift this heavy motorcycle off of the
captain's legs. And as soon as they did,
all three of them looked and they could
clearly see, you know, the the reason
there's all this blood all over the
pavement. There was this huge gash in
Captain Faly's leg right above his knee
that was just pouring out blood. And
Captain Falby, you know, he saw that and
he was already starting to feel
lightheaded from blood loss, but just
seeing this huge wound was totally
disorienting. Fortunately though, the
two men who had arrived on the scene to
help Captain Falby kept their composure.
And one of them actually noticed that
Captain Falby was wearing a necktie. He
had a formal police uniform on that had,
you know, a neck tie as part of it. And
he gently reached over and he told
Captain Falby to relax and he undid his
neck tie. Meanwhile, the other man, he
ran over to the side of the road where
this big tree was, and he got a stick, a
pretty sturdy stick. And so, the guy who
undid the neck tie, he tied it around
Captain Falby's leg above the wound,
basically cutting off circulation to
that wound, a tourniquet. He tied it
off. And then the other guy came back
over with the stick and he handed it to
the guy with the necktie. And he took
the stick and threaded it carefully
through the necktie that was now wrapped
around the captain's leg. and he began
twisting the stick, wrapping up the
fabric as he twisted it, which in turn
mechanically tightened that tourniquet
around the captain's leg, much tighter
than you could do, you know, without
something mechanical. Like, this is
somebody who clearly knew how to make a
real tourniquet out of sort of everyday
materials. And so, they tie off the
super tight tourniquet. They stop the
bleeding, and it ultimately saves
Captain Faly's life. In fact, by the
time Captain Falby actually got brought
to the hospital and they took off this
DIY tourniquet and patched him up for
real, the doctor would tell Captain
Folby that, you know, he was about 10
minutes away from death, from blood
loss. So, had it not been for those two
guys who showed up and made that
tourniquet, he very likely would have
died. 4 years later, on December 12th,
1938, Captain Falby was back at work.
And he had been, you know, ever since
maybe 6 months after his injury. He had
just gone back to work, fully recovered.
You know, he did have some scar tissue
on his leg, but he was basically back to
full capacity. And so on this particular
day, Captain Falby was on patrol like he
normally was in El Paso when he got a
call over the radio about a bad car
accident that had happened out on Route
80, which is a major road in that town.
And so, Captain Falby races over to the
scene and he sees there's this car
that's clearly veered off the road and
smashed into a tree. And the driver, or
who appears to be the driver, is sitting
still. in the driver's seat and they
were unconscious. And so Falby was the
first on the scene. He pulls over. He
gets off his bike. He rushes over to the
car and he carefully pulls this
unconscious man out of the car and he
lays him on the ground and he sees this
guy has a horrible gash in his leg and
it's bleeding profusely. But because
this basically mirrored the exact same
type of injury that Falby himself had
had four years earlier when he crashed
his motorcycle, Falby knew what to do.
He didn't have, you know, a a issued
tourniquet on hand, but he knew how to
make one. He had a necktie and there
were sticks on the side of the road. So,
as quick as he could, he rushed over,
grabbed a sturdy stick, took off his
neck tie, tied it around this man's leg,
used the stick to tighten it up even
further, and he cut off the bleeding to
that wound. And so, at this point, now
that Captain Felby has realized that,
okay, you know, this guy appears to be
stable now. He's not actively bleeding.
He's clearly still breathing, albeit
unconscious. But, you know, it seems
like he has a fighting chance here. So,
he's waiting for paramedics to show up
and take this guy to the hospital. And
he's just sitting there sort of, you
know, happy he was able to be here and
save this guy when he sort of looks at
this guy and he realizes something. The
man he had just saved with his DIY
tourniquet was literally the actual same
guy who had saved Captain Falby with a
DIY tourniquet four years earlier.
Captain Falby had never even gotten the
guy's name. They had not stayed in touch
after his accident. They had gone
separate ways. But now he's looking down
at this man and he's realizing it's the
same one. The guy's name was Alfred
Smith and he would make a full recovery.
But when he was rushed to the hospital,
they would say, you know, you were
within about maybe 10 minutes of
bleeding to death had it not been for
Captain Falby. So, literally, this DIY
tourniquet story played out almost
exactly the same way with these two guys
doing it to each other, but four years
apart. Later on, Captain Falby and
Alfred Smith would give an interview to
Ripley's Believe It or Not to talk about
the incredible coincidence that saved
both their lives. And when the
interviewer at some point congratulated
Captain Falby on his heroic efforts,
Falby simply stated, quote, "One good
tourniquet deserves another." You see,
Alfred Smith was the man who put the
tourniquet around my leg and saved my
life when my motorcycle hit that truck.
After all, one good tourniquet deserves
another.
And there you have it, ladies and
gentlemen.
>> Thank you to BetterHelp for sponsoring
today's video. When I left the military
in 2017, I left carrying a lot of
baggage that I didn't really know I had.
But what I was doing is basically
bottling it all up and then snapping at
people left and right. And the worst
part was that even though I didn't
really see this happening or why it was
happening, I knew my behavior was
destroying relationships left and right.
And it left me feeling very stuck and
isolated. The people close to me
eventually came to my aid and encouraged
me to seek professional help, go see a
therapist. And admittedly, I was pretty
resistant at first. I felt like I, you
know, could handle my business on my
own. But I did eventually relent and I
did see a therapist. And pretty quickly
I saw, you know, therapy can give me
something that I really couldn't give
myself. And that was a truly
non-judgmental space to be heard and
really talk openly about what was going
on in my life. And my therapist gave me
lots of perspective that I couldn't give
myself. And they taught methods to cope
with my anger and my sadness. And it
really kind of turned my life around.
Healing is not linear and you don't have
to do it alone. So, if you're struggling
right now and you don't know who to turn
to, consider giving therapy a try. And a
great therapy option is BetterHelp.
BetterHelp can connect you with a
licensed therapist who will listen and
help. Click the link in the description
below or go to betterhelp.com/mrbballin
to get 10% off your first month of
therapy.
[Music]
On the evening of December 16th, 1984, a
24-year-old electrical engineer named Ha
Ha Ron walked through the courtyard of a
pretty low rent Sidi apartment complex
in Hong Kong. He held hands with his
longtime girlfriend, 23-year-old Jen Yu.
The pair had just finished having dinner
together at Howron's apartment, which
was part of this complex. But now he was
walking his girlfriend across this
courtyard to the other side of this
complex where her apartment was located.
And so Haron always walked you home. The
pair had been together for a few years
now. They'd actually met in college
after a close mutual friend had
introduced them. And ever since then,
they had been inseparable. And so Helon
was just sort of protective of you. And
he felt like their neighborhood was not
very safe. And so anytime, especially at
night when he knew his girlfriend would
be sort of out and about in their
neighborhood, he would walk with her to
keep her safe. And so that's what he was
doing tonight. Eventually, the couple
reached the front door of the section of
this complex that would lead up to U's
apartment. And so, the two walked in
through the front door, and they made
their way over to the building's
elevator bank. There were two elevators.
How Ron reached over and pressed the up
button, and then he and you just stood
there and waited. And as they waited,
they began to hear the familiar sound of
one of the old elevator cars clanging
its way down the elevator shaft. These
were old and creaky and really kind of
sketchy elevator cars that both Hron and
you hated riding on. But you lived up on
the 13th floor and neither of them liked
walking up that many steps. And so it
was sort of like the only other choice
is to ride one of these elevator cars.
And so eventually the car came down, the
doors dinged, they opened up and nobody
was on the car. And so how Ron and you
stepped inside, they pressed 13, the
doors rattled to a close and they slowly
began going up. And the whole time
they're going up, neither of them spoke.
It was just kind of like anxious
anticipation that, you know, hopefully
this car will make it all the way up to
the 13th floor. And so as they're moving
up, you know, they're hearing the car
banging into the walls and it's it's
just so uncomfortable. But eventually
they do reach the 13th floor. It dings.
The doors open up and both of them are
so relieved when they step out of the
car onto solid ground and they make
their way over to you's apartment and
the two, you know, they give each other
a hug and kiss and say they had a really
nice time together and then you she
retreats into her apartment and how goes
back down the hallway and presses the
down button to go back down the
elevator. And sure enough, a couple of
seconds later, how Ron heard the
familiar sound of the elevator car
shaking and banging against the shaft as
it made its way up to him, there was a
bell sound. The doors opened up. Nobody
was on the elevator car. Alron stepped
inside, pressed the lobby button, turned
around, and watched as the doors closed.
And then slowly he began to go down. And
again, as he's going down, you know how
Ron had that same sort of nervous
energy, hoping this elevator didn't come
to a, you know, lurching stop or
something that it just got him down to
the ground safely. And so he's going
down. It's floor 12, 11, 10. Down he's
going. And then at floor 7, the car came
to a stop, but it was kind of a hard
stop. Not not like emergency status
hard, but it was a fairly hard stop at
floor 7. And so how he's instinctively
thinking, okay, well clearly someone on
the seventh floor has called the
elevator and the doors are going to open
any second here and you know someone's
going to get on. But as he's waiting for
the doors to open to alleviate this
sudden stress that oh my god is
something wrong here the doors don't
open and instead the elevator suddenly
lurches down another foot. It stops. But
clearly this is not normal elevator
behavior. There is something wrong with
this elevator. like his worst fears are
coming true and the doors still are not
opening. And so Harrron's looking around
wondering like what's he going to do?
Like what can he do? You know, he's
trying to tell himself that everything's
okay. You know, maybe the doors still
will open up, but they're not. And then
he begins to smell something. It was
almost like a sort of chemical smell. He
couldn't really place what it was. And
he's sort of looking around wondering
what's going on here. And his panic is
rising like this is a bad situation. Has
no idea what's happening, but clearly
something bad is going on here. And then
this already horrible situation gets a
thousand times worse because he looks
down and he sees the floor of the inside
of the elevator is now on fire. And as
he's realizing the floor is on fire and
that's what he was smelling is like this
burning smell, he sees his own legs are
now on fire. And so in a completely
panicked like fightor-flight moment,
Howon remembered that most elevator cars
have an escape hatch somewhere, usually
on the ceiling, and he looked up and he
couldn't believe it. There it was. There
was this escape hatch to get out of the
car. And so right away, that's what
Halron began trying to do. He kind of
scaled the walls of this car. He punched
open this hatch and he climbed out out
of the elevator, out of the fire, saving
his own life. And so while all this
chaos was happening in the elevator
shaft, Howon's girlfriend, you was in
her apartment looking out the window and
her view was basically the same
courtyard that she and Halron had walked
across just, you know, 5 minutes ago to
get to her apartment building. And it
was sort of customary that every time he
would drop her off at her apartment, she
would look out the window and wait for
him to come out the front door and she
would watch him walk back across that
same courtyard to his building on the
other side. And so you sort of
understood how long it would take, you
know, for how Ron to come down the
elevator and walk out the door. But now
it had been, you know, 5 6 7 8 minutes
and he still hadn't come out the front
door and there really wasn't any reason
for him not to have exited the building
at this point. And she started to get
worried. And so given the fact that you,
much like how Ron was fearful that those
old elevators in this building were
eventually going to get stuck while they
were on them, given she had that fear,
she instinctively was like, "Oh my gosh,
maybe he's stuck in the elevator. Like
that's why he hasn't left the building
yet." And so instinctively she left her
apartment and walked down the hallway to
the elevator bank and she looked up
above the doors and it showed where the
respective cars were located. and she
saw that one of the cars was stuck at
floor 7 and it wasn't moving up or down.
It didn't matter if she pressed the
button. That car would not go up or
down. The other car would, but not that
car. And so it convinced her that Hal
Ron has got to be trapped on that
elevator car. He's stuck right there. I
better call authorities. And so she did.
She called the fire department and said,
you know, hey, my my boyfriend, I
believe he's trapped in the elevator.
And so just a few minutes later, the
local fire department showed up to the
apartment complex and they walked up to
the seventh floor where they believed,
you know, this car was stuck. Now, they
were not in some crazy, you know,
emergency mode running down the hall to
open up this elevator car because
they're thinking, you know, it's it's
really just an inconvenience getting
stuck on an elevator car. It's not like
life and death. And so they just make
their way up to the seventh floor by
taking the stairs. And then on the
seventh floor, they go over to the
elevator bank where the two doors are to
the respective elevator cars. And on the
one that, you know, shows the the car is
stuck on floor 7, you know, it says the
number right above the door. They use
their tools to pry open the doors to
see, you know, the car right behind it.
And once they pry it open, they do see
the trapped elevator car, and it's not
exactly where it's supposed to be. It's
not sitting, you know, right in front of
the door. It's actually situated sort of
below the seventh floor. They can
basically only see the top of the
elevator car. Like this car has actually
gotten stuck between the seventh floor
and the sixth floor. But that in and of
itself was not a huge thing. I mean,
they could basically mechanically move
this car up and down if they needed to,
either up to the seventh or down to the
sixth to get whoever was on the car out.
What they noticed right away though,
which was the way bigger problem, is
they smelled and saw smoke, and it was
coming from this elevator car, the
trapped car. And so the firefighters
immediately go into, okay, we got to
figure out where this fire is coming
from. Is it coming from this elevator
car? Is it somewhere down below at the
bottom of the elevator shaft? Like, they
don't know. But from their perspective
outside looking into the shaft, they
could see that the hatch, the emergency
hatch on this stopped elevator car was
open cuz they can see the roof of this
car. And they're thinking, "Okay, you
know, maybe the trap guy is right in
there and we can look down, grab him,
pull him out, and deal with this fire."
And so they go in, they're yelling out
Hron's name. And they look down into
this elevator car. They're literally on
top looking through this hatch and they
see the carpet inside of this car is all
charred and burned and there's some
smoke sort of sitting inside the car,
but there's nobody inside the car. It's
empty. But they see there's blood all
over the inside and up on the walls. And
then they realize there's also blood
kind of coming up, you know, through
this hatch and it's on the top of the
elevator car. Clearly, you know, whoever
was in this car was badly hurt as they
exited out the roof. But now the
firefighters are wondering like, well,
where did he go? Did he fall down to the
bottom? I mean, because basically
there's just these two elevator cars
that move up and down inside of this
singular shaft. There's basically
nothing dividing the two shafts that
these elevator cars move in. It's kind
of like one big shaft. And so to the
side of this frozen car is this huge
shaft, multi-story shaft that goes all
the way to the ground. as they look over
the edge and they shine their light down
the elevator shaft because you know the
car on this side was up top. It was not
obstructing their view. And sure enough,
there is a man maybe one floor down who
looks very badly injured. He's got cuts
all over him. He's bleeding. It looked
like his ankle was broken. And he was
sort of huddled on this very small
platform basically one floor below. At
every floor when you walk onto the
elevator, when those doors open up,
there's like, you know, a 1 ft long
little platform that extends into the
shaft just enough that it meets the
entrance to the car. So, when the car
opens up, you walk across this little
platform into the elevator, the doors
shut, and it goes up or down. But if
you're in the elevator shaft, each floor
basically has that little protrusion,
that 1 ft, you know, small platform. And
there's the guy, presumably Hron, who is
positioned perched on the one right
below them on that little platform. And
so, of course, the firefighters forget
the fire cuz, you know, that's a
separate issue at this point, and they
got to go rescue Howon. And so, they go
down to the sixth floor, they open up
the doors, they grab How, they pull him
into the hallway where he is safe. You
know, he's obviously in an enormous
amount of pain. He's been burned. He's
got a broken ankle. He's in rough shape,
but it appears like he's going to
survive. And so as the firefighters
placed How Ron on a stretcher and he's
barely talking, you know, he's very
shaken up. He's just laying there. And
so at this point, you the girlfriend,
she found out the firefighters had saved
her boyfriend and he was on the sixth
floor. And so she comes charging down
the stairs, runs down the sixth floor
hallway to be by her boyfriend's side.
And she looks at Halron for the first
time and she just freezes and she stares
at him and she says, "That's not my
boyfriend." It would turn out this whole
elevator disaster was highly coordinated
because what neither Hon nor his
girlfriend you knew was that the same
mutual friend who had actually
introduced the two of them deeply
regretted it. He himself was in love
with you and he couldn't bear to see her
with another man. And so this mutual
friend whose name was Leo W Jang that
night he had secretly waited until he
was sure how Ron had climbed on the
elevator car by himself and then he had
cut off electricity to that car freezing
it at the seventh floor. Actually
between the seventh and the sixth floor
and then he climbed on top of the
elevator car opened up the hatch just
enough to pour kerosene into the car
with Howon. That was the smell that
Howon began to talk about and smell
inside the shaft. Like he clearly knew
there was something off, but Howon
didn't realize it was, you know, this
friend of his right above him. And then
before Hron could even understand what
was happening, Leu lit a match and threw
it into the elevator car. That was what
caused the big fire. But then when Hon
panicked and climbed up out of the hatch
to save himself, Leu was waiting for him
and he stabbed Hron and then threw him
off the roof of this elevator car where
he fell all the way down seven floors to
the bottom of the shaft where he died.
The man that was crouched on that
platform, you know, one floor below
where this car was was Leu. And
basically what he did is after murdering
Halron, he leapt onto that platform from
the top of this elevator car down onto
that platform sort of intentionally to
hurt himself to make it seem somehow
like you know he was just trying to help
but then you know basically fell and
hurt himself too like he didn't do
anything wrong but when they looked at
Hron inside the shaft he was clearly
stabbed and also they knew this fire had
been started on purpose it was clearly
arson and so once all this evidence had
piled up and it was pretty obvious vious
that Leu had done it. He did confess and
he was ultimately sentenced to life in
prison.
[Music]
One evening in February of 1966, a
34year-old man named Joseé Luis Pñena
walked down a staircase inside of a cafe
in Madrid, Spain. At the bottom of the
stairs was this sort of basement seating
area. It was pretty quiet. Only a few
people were down there. But Joseé
Louise, as soon as he was down there, he
saw his friend Fernando Sesma had
already found a booth on the other end
of the seating area. And he was
beckoning Joseé Louise over. And so
Joseé Louise, who had come here to meet
Fernando, eagerly walked over towards
him. And then before he even sat down,
Fernando, who was grinning ear to ear,
he held up this envelope and showed
Joseé Louise like, "I got to tell you
about this." So Joseé Louise and
Fernando were both members of a small
club called Bellenia Allegri, which
means happy whale in Spanish, and their
meetings were all about aliens and UFOs.
Now, Fernando was actually a post office
employee during the day, but at night,
he was the deacto leader of this club,
and he'd always been fascinated by
aliens. As for Joseé Louise, he actually
was much more of a skeptic. He actually
kind of actively did not believe in
aliens, UFOs, or anything paranormal.
But about a month prior, he'd had this
sort of inexplicable, you know, UFO
sighting or he didn't even know what it
was. He was driving along and thought he
saw something in the sky that didn't
necessarily make him a believer, but he
didn't know who to talk to about this
thing he had seen. He couldn't make
sense of it. And so that's how he had
found his way into this group. It was
just because it was an outlet to talk
about this weird thing he had been
through. And to be honest, he didn't
know if he'd be staying any longer than
maybe the next couple of weeks. He was
just here for now. But regardless, you
know, Joseé Louise and Fernando had made
plans to meet up in this cafe tonight to
sort of catch up on all things about the
club before their actual club meeting
that was going to happen maybe 30
minutes from when they were actually
meeting. But as Joseé Louise is sitting
down, Fernando's got this envelope that
he's really excited about. And once
Joseé Louise sits down, Fernando puts it
in front of him and he's like, "Look,
look, there's no return address." and he
points there's like this strange symbol
on the outside of this envelope and it
just looks sort of foreign. Like Joseé
Louise didn't really even know what he
was looking at. But Fernando, who again
is a full believer, he says to Joseé
Louise, he's like, "I just got this
letter and I'm going to show it to the
club tonight because I think it's from
an alien." Now, when Joseé Louise heard
this, you know, he was open to the idea
of UFOs being a thing because again, he
couldn't explain what happened to him,
but he just felt like, "Give me a
bring." Like, "What? An alien sent you a
letter? Why? why would they send you a
letter? And he sort of said as much to
Fernando, but Fernando, he was ready for
this. Like he knew Joseé Louise was a
skeptic and he knew he would cut this
letter apart. But Fernando, he took the
envelope back, you know, before Joseé
Louise could say anything more about how
fake this was. And he pulled out the
letter inside. And the letter, it was
typed out, so it wasn't by hand. It was
by typewriter. And the writer wrote that
they were literally from an alien race
called the Umites. And they had come
from a planet called Umo. And they said
that, you know, the Umites had very
advanced technology and they'd actually
already been living on Earth for the
last 16 years. However, humans didn't
recognize them because they sort of
looked like normal people. And so this
alien writer said for all these years
they had been searching for, you know, a
true believer to share this secret with.
And apparently the believer they had
found was Fernando. Now, Joseé Louise
could tell that Fernando was really
excited. And so he sort of throttled
back how much he sort of rained on his
parade here. And he just let him have
his moment and said, "Wow, you know,
that's really interesting." And then
before long, the other members of their
club came into this basement seating
area inside this cafe. And as soon as
they were all assembled, Fernando got up
to the front of the room and he held up
this envelope and he said, "You won't
believe it. I got this letter. It's from
an alien race. They want to talk to me.
Like, can you believe this? We finally
have proof. You know, the aliens are
here." And unbelievably as he says this,
Joseé Louise is looking out to get the
reaction of the other folks in the club
to see how invested they are, you know,
in this new revelation. And Joseé Louise
can't believe it when others in this
club begin reaching into their bags and
pulling out identical looking envelopes
with these strange symbols on them. And
they're like, "We got these letters,
too. We just got them last night. We
brought them here for this meeting. Can
you believe it?" And so the whole
meeting was completely dominated by, you
know, talks of the the Umite alien race
and how, you know, these letters have
got to be legitimate. Like this can't be
a prank the way Joseé Louise said it
could be a prank. Like this has got to
be real. Who would want to prank us?
We're just this little group that, you
know, investigates the paranormal. Like
why would anyone care about pranking us?
And Joseé Louise said to them, "That's
why. Because you believe in the
paranormal and they're playing into
that. Like you're the perfect target to
be pranked. that's why this is likely
happening. But pretty much the entire
club disagreed with Joseé Louise and
they reminded him, Fernando in
particular, that he should recall the
club's motto, which was to believe
everything until proven otherwise.
Basically, the whole group was demanding
that Joseé Louise keep an open mind
because this might be the exact moment
most of them were all waiting for. A
little over a year later in June of 1967
and Joseé Louise was back inside of that
basement seating area of that cafe in
Madrid, Spain. To this point, Joseé
Louise had continued attending these
meetings of the Bellena Allegri. You
know, he had thought about leaving a
couple of times, especially as this
whole Umite fervor had really took hold
inside the club. He just he didn't buy
it, but he had stuck it out and
continued attending meetings. But on
this particular day, he was here for a
very specific reason. It was because he
had seen an article in the local
newspaper that he knew the club would be
really eager to see. So at this point,
Fernando actually was writing a weekly
column in the newspaper about the Umites
because shortly after getting that first
letter and all the other members of the
club getting those letters, he had
written to the news. They had been
really interested and asked for weekly
updates. And sure enough, over the past
year, the club continued receiving these
letters, Fernando included, you know,
from the Umites, whoever they were, and
he would write these update columns. And
really, by this point, a year later,
that column had become really popular in
Madrid. And so people of Madrid were
pretty invested in the ommites and, you
know, whatever was happening with them.
And also adding to the intrigue was
these letters were no longer just
arriving on the doorsteps of Bellena
Allegri members. They were arriving in
front of random people's homes all over
Madrid. Like random people were being
contacted by, you know, this alien race.
Now, Joseé Louise still very much
believed that there is no way this could
be real. Like, this can't actually be
aliens. But the Umites had basically
become the only conversation topic in
the club every time they met. Like, it
was all they ever talked about. And it
increasingly felt like it was a lot of
what Madrid talked about. I mean, this
was a big deal at the time. But today,
the reason Joseé Louise had brought the
newspaper to bring to the group was
actually because, you know, they had
published something that even to Joseé
Louise was pretty unbelievable. You
know, it wasn't an article that Fernando
had published. It was not, you know,
another recounting of another letter
showing up. It was actually, you know,
this newspaper themselves covering what
appeared to be a local UFO sighting. And
apparently, somebody had captured a
photo of this, you know, presumed UFO.
And that photo had been published in the
news. And wouldn't you know, on the
outside of this alien craft was that
same strange symbol that adorned the
front of all the Umite letters that
Fernando and the the club members and
all people of Madrid were getting from
these Umites. It was the same symbol.
And so it sort of felt like for the
first time it was not just, you know,
letters that could be fabricated and and
sent to the masses. It was like this
vehicle that had shown up in Madrid that
had that same symbol like it had to be
the ommites. Also remember it's 1967 and
so faking photographs was very hard to
do at least, you know, making something
look convincing. And so that's why Joseé
Louise, you know, he had brought this
newspaper in to show the other members
of this club to be like, you know what,
I got to say this is pretty
unbelievable. And you know, the reaction
from the club was equally amazed. They
had all already seen this photo. I mean,
they are completely locked in on all
things um and so this photo was sort of
like the centerpiece of that day's
discussion. And Joseé Louise found
himself sort of admitting that, you
know, this is pretty unbelievable and I
don't know what to make of it. But by
the end of the meeting, Joseé Louise
still cautioned the group like, look,
you know, I know this looks so real and
it feels so real. I mean, I'm I'm
bringing this to you. I think this is
pretty unbelievable, but there's just
got to be an angle here. Somebody has to
be faking this. like there isn't a way
that some alien species is doing this.
This just doesn't feel real to me. But
at this point, it was like everybody
shut them down. They're like, "Hey, you
brought this to us today. You're the one
saying this is hard to deny. Like this
makes it feel real." And so at this
point, you know, forget your dissenting
opinion. What we need to do as a group
is take the news of the um and this
photograph and all the letters and not
just show it to the rest of Spain, but
we need to show it to the whole world.
And so sure enough, after that, Fernando
began going on TV and insisting the
Umites were real, which actually did
cause mass panic across all of Spain.
People couldn't explain the thousands of
letters and that UFO photo. And so
belief in the Uites really caught on.
And while Fernando and seemingly the
entire general public of Spain became
increasingly radicalized, Joseé Louise
grew more isolated from his friends in
Bellena Allegri. And soon he quit
attending meetings altogether. And then
shortly after that, he began going on
TV, but not to advocate for the belief
in the ommites, but the opposite to say,
"Stop believing in this. There's no way
this is real." But nobody really
listened to him. You know, the Umite
story had really taken on a life of its
own, and it was sort of beginning to
spin out of control. A few years after
the Umite letters began showing up and
making headlines, two men had lied down
on railroad tracks and basically taken
their own lives by letting the train run
them over. And police actually found
notes in these men's pockets that just
said, "The aliens call us." And given
the timing of, you know, their deaths,
it seemed like it had to be connected to
the omites. Then two Spanish sisters
died in a murder suicide and police
discovered they had been receiving Umite
letters that might have contributed to
this crime. By the 1970s, there were
also multiple Umite related cults
operating in Spain. And one of those
cults targeted young boys. And in the
early 1970s, when Joseé Louise's own son
was 7 years old, that child was targeted
by one of these cults to be brought in
because of his father. like they were
trying to bring this child in to be
exposed to who knows what just because
of Joseé Louise's public stature as it
related to the Omites. Now, Joseé
Louise's son would not be pulled into
that cult. He would be just fine. But
for Joseé Louise, like this was pretty
eye opening and terrifying. You know,
the idea that his family could be
targeted because of this omite stuff was
crazy. And so around that same time,
Joseé Louise stopped trying to tell
people to not believe in this stuff and
instead retreated from the public eye
and just tried to live a quiet, isolated
life. Over the next several decades,
people all over Spain continued
receiving omite letters and nobody knew
why. And these cults that, you know,
sort of focused on the ommites continued
to flourish and continued to believe
that absolutely the ommites are real. As
for Joseé Louise, he really did try to
live a private life away from all this
craziness, but it was hard to escape it.
I mean, he would see Fernando on the
news all the time talking about the
Umites, and he even published a book
about it. I mean, it was kind of
everywhere. But everything changed in
1996,
30 years after the first Umite letter
was received. One night in 1996, people
all over Spain gathered in front of
their TVs very expectantly as there was
going to be this special report about
the Umites. And when the guest of honor,
who was going to be a big part of the
special report came on screen and began
talking about the Umites, it truly
shocked the entire country. This person
explained that in their own lives, they
had recently had a near-death
experience. And that experience had made
them realize it was finally time to
admit to the world that they had made
the whole Umite thing up. It really was
a hoax. They said they had written those
first Umite letters and sent them to
Bolena Allegri because they believed
they would be susceptible to believing
in the hoax. And they also said they
really did fake that photograph that was
put in the newspaper of the UFO with the
strange symbol that matched the symbol
on all those letters. But the person
said, you know, after that they sort of
had no intention to keep up the hoax.
However, the story kind of took off and
all these copycats began sending their
own omite letters to random people all
over Spain and then the news picked it
up and it was everywhere. And even
though this person was trying so hard to
literally tell the world that they faked
this thing, nobody listened. The hoax
was none other than Joseé Louise. He
literally had done this just to show the
Bellena Allegri how easy it was to get
people to believe in aliens and
conspiracies because that's what people
want. He basically wanted to show them
that he was skeptical and he had this
UFO experience and he was trying to get
to the bottom of it, but everyone's
like, "Oh, it's got to be aliens." And
it's like, "No, let's step back and be
rational." He was trying to prove a
point that look, I faked aliens writing
to you when you all believed it. Like,
how are we going to actually figure out
what's real and what's not? But he
wasn't expecting it to take on a life of
its own. However, Joseé Louise's
confession never actually reached
Fernando because Fernando died years
before Joseé Louise admitted this really
was a hoax. And so, he died absolutely
still believing that Umites were real.
And despite the fact there were at least
four deaths linked to this UMO craze and
also there were all these cults that
were doing who knows what, probably
illicit and illegal things also tied to
the UMO hoax. Despite all that, Joseé
Louise never faced any criminal charges.
He died in 2014.
Thank you so much for watching. Let me
know what you thought of today's episode
in the comments. And remember, we have
hundreds of videos for you to binge
right now. But if you're looking for a
recommendation from me of that one video
that's worth your time, well, it's this
one right here. So give it a watch. All
right, until next time. See you.